una conmoción es un tipo de lesión
cerebral traumática leve que puede
ocurrir cuando su cabeza recibe un duro
golpe
su cerebro es el órgano más frágil en el
cuerpo con la misma textura y
consistencia que la gelatina
su cráneo brinda un escudo protector
duro alrededor de su cerebro
una sustancia acuosa llamada fluido
cefalorraquídeo rodea su cerebro
el fluido cefalorraquídeo protege su
cerebro contra impactos con la pared de
su cráneo durante los movimientos
diarios de la cabeza
este efecto de amortiguación protege los
billones de células nerviosas llamadas
neuronas dentro de su cerebro
cada neurona se comunica con otras
neuronas a través de señales eléctricas
que viajan a lo largo de una extensión
larga como un hilo llamada un axón
un duro golpe a su cabeza puede provocar
que su cerebro golpee el interior de su
cráneo
durante el impacto su cerebro se estruja
contra el interior de su cráneo enviando
ondas de choque a través de su cerebro
estas ondas de choque rompen o estiran
los axones de algunas neuronas este
trauma es llamado una lesión axonal
difusa o cizallamiento axonal los axones
dañados reducen la función cerebral
normal interrumpiendo la comunicación
entre las neuronas
dependiendo de dónde está lesionado su
cerebro los síntomas físicos de
conmoción pueden incluir dolor de cabeza
náuseas
y mareos o coordinación muscular
deficiente
sensibilidad a la luz visión borrosa
zumbido en los oídos
habla desarticulada
y pérdida de la conciencia usted puede
tener síntomas mentales y emocionales
incluyendo desorientación
confusión
pérdida de memoria
e incapacidad para enfocarse y
concentrarse
irritabilidad
y depresión
para una conmoción leve su médico le
aconsejará a descansar y monitorear sus
síntomas para asegurarse de que no
empeoren
usted puede recibir recetas de
analgésicos leves como acetaminofeno o
ibuprofeno
solo tome medicamentos recomendados por
su médico
otros como alcohol puede hacer más lenta
la curación de su cerebro
ya sea que ha ido o no con el médico si
experimenta pérdida de conciencia
un dolor de cabeza que no desaparece
vómitos o habla desarticulada usted debe
buscar atención médica de emergencia
estos síntomas son señales de peligro
para complicaciones graves de conmoción